we should just take this trash down as
it we get it look at this
accumulation of people on outside
george i didn't know this was here
oh man it's like we're the only homeless
people with a home
hurt my wrist what is this
what is this what is this did charles
manson do this
what is this what do you mean why would
he have done that because it looks like
a serial killer did it but why
because it's so messy it's flowers
yeah you've exposed yourself to a serial
killer i didn't know what it was
and you know what it is you're circular
you've killed people great
congratulations you've killed people
we've got two of them away yeah
i mean we can donate them too are there
serial killers
i'm really coordinated that was the
train set that cal got
okay so we're gonna be throwing that
that's recycled
yep that too that too yeah i know how
many hands do i have i have two hands
how is this wet it didn't rain at all it
didn't rain at all this just sweats this
box
good thing i look so manly when i do it
what's this we i don't know
where was it upstairs we just can't use
it it's a tv
back so you know what it is i said what
is this you said i don't know i said
where was it you said it's a tv bag
i mean i i know it's a part of one but
like whatever you understand what i'm
saying
about how i said it i do know but like
what am i an engineer
no no no but that's not a problem though
the problem is when i say what is this
you say i don't know and i say where was
it and you say well it's for the back of
the tv
you're answering the first question and
the second question well you were just
following up the question too soon i
wasn't totally done answering but that's
one of the things that you do you ask
you answer the wrong question and then i
have to ask another question to get the
question that i wanted i have to ask the
wrong question to get the right answer
okay i want to hear all the stuff that
you do that's bad
no i know all the stuff that i did is
bad because i've been going over it and
over and over
in my head but i could tell you more
stuff
[Music]
guess where it hurt i don't care
sweetheart it hurt right there when i
did it
you have to kick it up so you roll it
i